WILLIAM LI: So I
think our reason
for really giving a public
face to the class in the course
itself but also on
Open CourseWare,
I think there's a number of
different dimensions associated
with that.
First I think it's sort
of personal, I think,
that Professor Teller
started this class
and we really want to make these
materials available to people
and really kind of build
on that legacy of the work
that he's done.
And if the work that we've
contributed this year
can help the class
continue on and continue
to grow and flourish, I think
that's a really exciting part.
The second piece I think
is really for the students,
the opportunity to interact with
people in the wider community,
to share their work, the
work that they have done.
I think all of our students
are very proud of the work
that they've done.
They really got
into the projects
and working with their clients.
And so in having a public
showcase at the end
and having them communicate
their work online, in video,
or through OCW, I think is part
of the learning experience,
I think.
And the third piece
is that we really
think there's a big
opportunity in terms
of assistive
technology education
or kind of
project-based education
that we work with
people with disabilities
in the Cambridge or Boston area.
But in a lot of ways,
this model could
be applied to a lot of other
places, a lot of other colleges
or universities in other towns
or cities in the United States
or around the world.
There's really a huge need
or a huge opportunity,
I think, to work in
assistive technology.
A lot of potential partners
to spread geographically.
And we want to kind of
communicate how we did here.
And maybe share
some materials that
make it a little bit
easier for somebody
thinking about doing
this, or maybe just
to inspire them
to think about how
they might be able to work on a
course or a project like this.
GRACE TEO: I think one of
the more public aspects
of the class as
well was the fact
that we asked our
students to write up
blog posts over the semester.
So all of them had to write
four different blog posts
on a public blog for the class.
And one thing that's
very important to me
when we teach about
disability is that we're not
coming in as saviors.
And we're not coming
in to like, oh,
let's share our wonderful
engineering knowledge with you.
One of the central
aspects of this class
is that it user-centered design.
And we have to recognize
that the clients themselves
understand their
disability the best.
And they understand
the type of challenges
that come with living with
a disability the best.
So one of the great things about
having those blog posts was
that the community outside could
also engage with the students
and say, wow, this
is a good idea,
maybe this is not a
good idea, have you
considered this other aspect.
And so we think that
by engaging our users,
that also just makes the design
process a lot more rigorous.